River in China
where each year a massive tidal ball
wave surges upstream at about 25 miles
per hour you don't expect to see massive
waves here this is not a breaking shore
this is a river to give you a scallop
the size of the ways you can see the
boats nearly being overcome by this
massive massive wave fortunately for us
massive waves attract daredevil surfers
I think this is a really great place for
surfers because the waves seem to last a
lot longer they are also extremely
powerful and large this is probably very
much a surfer stream this wave ride made
a giant splash on the internet with over
one-and-a-half million hits so who's
responsible for the Chinese rivers
massive wave is actually being caused by
the pull of the moon because the moon
has got a gravitational field okay so if
it's a naturally occurring phenomenon
why doesn't this wave occur all the time
this only happens roughly once a year in
China you got to get the Sun and the
moon lighting up that's when you get the
strongest gravitational pull because the
Sun is pulling very strong in the moon's
pulling strong so you get this huge pull
literally pulling the water up and then
you just have it happen perfectly in
this one location or the geometry of the
river shallow enough but comes down
together so that it creates this wave
and it just propagates down the river
you're seeing the influence of the force
of gravity the moon's pull the sun's
pull right here on earth in a tangible
form and that really gets me excited